well the u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken is due to be speaking at the
state department we'll bring you all of
the context and all of that live when it
happens and of course what's it all
about well the final u.s plane is taking
off from kabul the war in afghanistan is
officially over the confirmation came
from the pentagon within the past hour
and a half bringing to an end two
decades of conflict and of course two
weeks of chaos on the ground a c-17
transport plane took off at 1929 gmt and
cleared afghan air space as the
announcement was made
i'm here to announce the completion of
our withdrawal from afghanistan in the
end of the military mission to evacuate
american citizens
third country nationals and vulnerable
afghans the last c-17 lifted off from
hamad karzai international airport on
august 30 this afternoon at 3 29 pm east
coast time and the last manned aircraft
is now clearing the airspace above
afghanistan
we will soon release a photo of the last
c-17 departing afghanistan with major
general chris donahue and the u.s
ambassador to afghanistan ross wilson
aboard
while the military evacuation is
complete the diplomatic mission to
ensure additional u.s citizens and
eligible afghans who want to leave
continues
well more than a hundred thousand people
have left on u.s flights in just the
past two weeks but thousands of afghans
hoping to leave the country now under
taliban control are being left behind
including many who worked as u.s allies
rob mcbride is joining us now live from
kabul
rob it's been a historic moment but also
a solemn moment
absolutely i mean this was uh some
incredible scenes here in kabul um what
is a very historic night the the finally
the ending of 20 years of military
involvement by the united states in the
country words started to spread here
very quickly just after midnight local
time so we were already into the 31st of
august a date which is very important
which will be noted in history books in
years to come this was the date the
deadline set as the departure of the us
and the u.s was good to its word it left
on the 31st but just after midnight into
this day tuesday
and word started to spread on social
media that uh the
the the wheels up were on the last
aircraft taking off from hamid karzai
international airport we started to get
uh some email traffic from the taliban
saying they were taking over control
confirming that the last of the american
aircraft had left then we started uh
interestingly to have something of an
eerie silence we've for days now been
hearing all sorts of aircraft noises of
patrolling warplanes overhead earlier on
monday we saw a b-52 bomber pass over
kabul and then there's been this
thundering background noise of these
aircraft big lumbering c-17s taking off
transport planes taking off from the
airport as this evacuation has continued
and
quite quickly within about 10 minutes or
so as we started to get confirmation
that the last of the americans had gone
this noise started to drift away there
was something of an eerie silence and
then that was quickly replaced by this
rolling gunfire a building cacophony it
began at the airport itself we started
to see tracer gunfire firing up into the
air so it was obviously some sort of
celebratory gunfire and then very
quickly this was picked up across the
city as words started to spread between
taliban groups and taliban fighters in
various locations and very soon the
whole of the skyline around the city was
lit up with guns of all sorts of sizes
and description firing into the air at
this news that finally after 20 years
the u.s have gone
and rob there's been so much attention
leading up to this deadline um this
moment that has now come but i suppose
the inevitable question is what happens
next and of course we're left with a
pretty complex picture
absolutely well for the
taliban
themselves they have to form a
government they've got a a country to
run they unexpectedly
came almost inherited the country with
the collapse of the hamid cars of the
previous ashraf ghani regime very
quickly collapsing two weeks ago they
found themselves in control here in
kabul and very quickly they have had to
run around and are still in the process
of forming uh their government there's
no kind of power sharing that we were
talking about before they are in charge
but they also inherit all of the myriad
problems that comes with afghanistan
after decades of war with all of the uh
problems uh that uh it it has
encountered over the years uh so it has
really got its work to do and the most
important thing that there are a number
of things on that list but one of the
priorities is at the airport itself that
was
seeing the completion of the evacuation
dealing with the chaotic scenes there
and somehow putting an airport back
together again remember this is the
airport at kabul is just about the only
entry and exit point that afghanistan
has really had for what the best part of
two weeks but it's been controlled by
the u.s now the u.s has gone they've
taken air traffic control with it
they're pretty much left a shell of an
airport there it is now up to the
taliban possibly with the help of
foreign partner countries to
re-establish all of the systems that
make an airport work such as its air
traffic control its security and all the
rest it has to
do that the land borders largely remain
closed it has thousands of people uh
moving towards those land borders to try
to get out of afghanistan so it has a
brain drain to deal with it has massive
migrations of people it has to somehow
convince people to stay within the
country and then there are fears from
the people themselves of course that all
of these promises of this being a new
type of taliban regime that it is a
softer more inclusive government it
doesn't mean much
until people see that matched with
actions and a lot of people as we know
simply aren't waiting they are heading
for land borders and they will once they
have the opportunity it seems and we
have airports open and running again be
trying to get onto flights and the other
problem for the united states and for
all of the people who still believe that
they have a right to go to the united
states they they believe they have a
right to protection from the u.s to stop
being uh
rip stop reprisals from the taliban as
they take over because they have some
sort of connection uh with the u.s
military or other foreign forces there
is the problem of how the u.s through
diplomacy through the state department
can try to process those people to try
to leave afghanistan to go to the u.s or
indeed to other countries such as the uk
and that remains a huge problem that
will require all sorts of diplomacy
cooperation from the taliban government
who possibly will not want to contribute
to what is a continuing drain on people
leaving the country that it needs to
make the country work so there's an
awful lot of problems ahead
the airport the departure of the
americans in some ways despite all of
the chaos and the the trauma of the past
couple of weeks that was almost the more
straightforward problem to resolve we
knew it was going to be resolved at
somehow and at some point and it would
be probably resolved on the 31st of
august which it has now in many respects
for many different actors and partners
in the
ongoing afghan crisis the problems
really start
ron mcbride joining me there live from
kabul rob thank you
well the u.s president says he will
address his nation on tuesday but in the
past few minutes the white house has
released a statement saying the past 17
days has seen our troops execute the
largest airlift in u.s history
evacuating over 120 000 u.s citizens
citizens of our allies and the afghan
allies of the united states they've done
it with unmatched courage
professionalism and resolve now our
20-year military presence in afghanistan
has ended
well gabe elizondo was listening to the
pentagon briefing and joins me now live
from washington d.c gabe there was an
extraordinary amount of detail and a
level of frankness wasn't there in that
briefing from the pentagon earlier just
bring us up to date with what happened
in that briefing
yeah that's right uh kenneth mckenzie
the general who's in charge of central
command was very frank
after he announced that all u.s troops
had completely pulled out of the airport
he then followed that up by saying
there's not one single u.s service
member still in afghanistan there was a
lot in that briefing but he confirmed
that since august 14th
the u.s military has helped evacuate
000
civilians including about 6 000 u.s
citizens he did say
not all people that wanted to leave they
were able to get out
we're hearing from the state department
that they believe that there are still
less than 250 u.s citizens in
afghanistan that were not able to get to
the airport uh in the statement by joe
biden that you just read he went on to
also say that
that biden said that it was the
unanimous conclusion from all of his top
commanders that he should not extend
the deadline past august 31st and that
is why the u.s pulled out when it did
mckinsey the general also uh stating uh
that the last military planes that left
hamad kaza international airport carried
the top u.s military general on the
ground as well as
the top u.s diplomat the
ambassador to afghanistan and once that
plane left and it was wheels up
essentially at that point the u.s
military involvement had completely
ended in afghanistan in terms of any
sort of troops or even diplomats for
that matter on the ground he was also
very complimentary quite frankly towards
the taliban saying that the taliban were
in his words and i'll get the exact
words here in his words the taliban were
helpful and useful
over the past several days and weeks in
helping to secure the perimeter of the
airport he said that
the threats against u.s service members
the last few days and weeks did not come
at all from the taliban but instead were
coming from isil k so uh clearly uh uh
mckinsey felt uh
complimentary of the taliban and their
cooperation if you will that cooperation
did not go so far as to where the u.s
told the taliban in advance exactly when
the last planes would be leaving the
airport he said they did not tell the
taliban that
in terms of isil k it was interesting
mckinsey said he believes that there are
about 2 000 isil k fighters
still within afghanistan he insinuated
that a lot of them uh were from us the
prisons the the prisoners that were let
out of some of the jails in afghanistan
he feels some of them
uh were from there and he said that the
taliban would have their hands full
dealing with isil k
in the coming uh
weeks and months quite frankly
though however bottom line to all of
this is the 20-year war in afghanistan
or at least the 20-year presence of u.s
troops in afghanistan
officially is now over gabriel
alessandro they're joining us with the
very latest live from washington d.c
gabe thank you
will u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken is expect